♪
>> Tucker: HOSPITALS THAT
ABUSE CHILDREN THAT BELIEVE
THEIR GENITALS ARE FINALLY
BLESSEDLY BEING SHUT DOWN.
VANDERBILT CLOSED ITS YOUTH
GENDER CLINIC AFTER THE DAILY
WIRE EXPOSED THEM.
IN GREAT BRITAIN THE GOVERNMENT
CLOSED FOR GENDER REASSIGNMENT
CLINIC AFTER THEY GOT SUED BY
THOUSANDS OF PARENTS.
TO LITIGATION STOPS MUTILATION.
THESE KINDS OF CLOSURES ARE
ABOUT TO BECOME MORE COMMON.
OF FRIEND IS REPRESENTING A
YOUNG WOMAN WHO BIOLOGIC WOMAN
WHO WAS TOLD SHE COULD BECOME A
MAN SURGICALLY.
NOW THEY ARE SUING THE DOCTORS
WHO DID THIS TO HER.
SHE IS THE CHAIRMAN OF THE
REPUBLICAN NATIONAL LAWYERS
ASSOCIATION AND IS JOINED BY
THANK YOU BOTH SO MUCH FOR
COMING ON.
WE'LL BECOME A FIRST EAGLE.
TELL US WHY YOU ARE SUING.
>> IT'S MEDICAL MALPRACTICE CASE
.
I WAS TOLD THE ADULTS THAT PUT
ME IN HARM'S WAY ACCOUNTABLE
BECAUSE WHAT HAPPENED TO ME IS
HORRIBLE, BUT IT'S ALSO IT
DIDN'T ONLY HAPPEN TO ME.
IT'S HAPPENING TO CHILDREN ALL
OVER THE U.S., ALL OVER THE LIS
AND IT'S SPREADING ALL OVER THE
WORLD.
I WANT TO BE ABLE TO CREATE A
PRECEDENT FOR OTHER PEOPLE THAT
HAVE BEEN IN MY SITUATION TO
FIND JUSTICE THEMSELVES.
>> Tucker: HOW OLD WERE YOU
WHEN YOU WERE TOLD BY A DOCTOR
THAT YOU COULD BECOME A
DIFFERENT?
>> I WAS 12.
TO GET YOU WERE YEARS OLD GREAT.
>> I ASSUME AT 12 YOU BELIEVE
WHAT A THE DOCTOR TELLS YOU.
>> MY PARENTS TRUSTED THEM AS
WELL.
I WAS 12 YEARS OLD WHEN I FIRST
EXPRESSED TO THEM THAT I CAN'T
DISTRESS WITH MY GENDER, WITH
BEING FEMALE AND I WANTED TO TR
THEIR SHIFT TO MAIL, THEY WERE
CONCERNED, AND THEY WANTED WHAT
WAS BEST FOR ME, THAT, BUT THEY
SOUGHT PROFESSIONAL HELP, AND
FROM THEN ON, I WAS BASICALLY
REFERRED IN MY GENDER IDENTITY
WITHOUT ANY QUESTIONING FROM AN
MEDICAL PROFESSIONALS AND THEY
PUSHED TRANSITIONING AS THEIR
WAY TO TREAT GENDER DYSPHORIA.
>> IT'S SO UPSETTING.
THEY CAN'T THEY COMMITTED
SURGERY ON YOU.
>> IS.
>> IS, WHEN I WAS 15 RESULT,
THEY REMOVED BOTH OF MY, AND I
WILL NEVER HAVE THEM BACK.
AS AN ADULT, I WILL NEVER BE
ABLE TO BREAST-FEED WHATEVER
CHILDREN I WILL HAVE.
AT AN EVEN KNOW IT BECAUSE I WA
PUT ON PUBERTY BLOCKERS AND
TESTOSTERONE AT 13 YEARS OLD, I
DON'T KNOW IF I'LL BE ABLE TO
CONCEIVE A CHILD NATURALLY.
BECAUSE I MADE AN ADULT DECISIO
IS A CHILD.
>> IT'S UNBELIEVABLE THIS COULD
HAPPEN IN AMERICA.
>> Tucker: HOW OLD ARE YOU NOW
AND HOW DO YOU FEEL ABOUT WHAT
THEY DID DO?
>> I AM 18 YEARS OLD NOW, AND
QUITE FRANKLY I AM DEVASTATED
WITH WHAT HAS HAPPENED TO ME.
IT HAS BEEN HARD TO COPE WITH
THE LOSS OF MY, AND IT HAS
AFFECTED OTHER AREAS OF MY
HEALTH AS WELL.
I'M REALLY NOT SURE ABOUT THE
OVERALL PICTURE OF MY
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH, AND THE
TREATMENTS HAVE MADE ME VERY
SICKLY.
>> HOW CAN THIS BE LEGAL?
>> TUCKER, THE CENTER FOR
AMERICAN LIBERTY WHO IS
REPRESENTING CHLOE BELIEVES IT
IS ILLEGAL.
OUR WEBSITE HAS THAT LETTER, A
VERY DETAILED LETTER THAT
DETAILS ALL OF THE MEDICAL
SYMPTOMS THAT CHLOE HAS AND THA
MEDICAL MALPRACTICE.
AND FRANKLY MUTILATION THAT WAS
PERPETRATED BY THESE MEDICAL
PROFESSIONALS GREATLY INTEND TO
STOP IT, BUT WE WANT TO HEAR
FROM OTHER PEOPLE WHO HAVE HAD
THESE PROBLEMS AS WELL.
WE WANT TO SHUT THESE BARBARIC
AND UNNATURAL PRACTICES DOWN.